Speaker 1: Cocaine has been found at the White
House, and of course, this is triggering everybody
that you can imagine would be triggered. Let's
first start with the facts and then we'll go on
to the commentary. Politico reports suspicious
powder found at the White House when Biden
was gone was cocaine, was cocaine. According to
Associated Press sources, Secret Service agents
were doing routine rounds on Saturday, Sunday
when they found the white powder in an area
accessible to tour groups, not in any particular
West Wing office. The White House was briefly
evacuated Sunday evening. Biden wasn't there. He
was at Camp David, and preliminary tests showed
it was cocaine. According to law enforcement,
secret Secret Service agents were doing rounds.
They found the powder in this area. The officials
are not authorized to discuss the investigation.
There was an evacuation at 845. Now, you might
say, why would you evacuate for Coke? Before
they knew it was Coke, they thought it could be
anthrax or who knows what it might have been.
They did a rapid test and it was indeed cocaine.
It was the White House reopened and that is it.
Now, we're going to be going through some
of the typical reactions from the right. And
this includes it was Hunter Biden. Imagine if this
happened under Trump, etc.. I want to just put out
there. I received a bunch of emails from people
saying, David, you're not going to cover this.
You're scared to cover this. It's the typical
thing. If a story doesn't go with your narrative,
you ignore it. What narrative have I ever stated
that this would contradict? Have I been Have I
spent the last ten years saying, Folks, there are
no drugs at the White House and now cocaine at
the White House has destroyed my narrative. But
I don't know why you're thinking I would ignore
this story. Importantly, the area is accessible
to tour groups. It's an area where people from
the public walk through. It makes it a much
less interesting story. If this was found in,
you know, the personal residence of Joe Biden,
then it might be a more interesting story,
although maybe it wouldn't be, I don't know.
But the reaction from the right wing extremists
has been extreme, but also sadly predictable. And
we're going to talk about it in the next segment.
For now, I do want to tell you about Donald
Trump's reaction to the cocaine in the White House